à 21 ans elle fait partie des golfeuses
à suivre en cette année 2010 21
charlotte liothier vient de remporter
les internationaux d'italie dame ce 21
mars
victoire importante dans sa jeune
carrière c'est une guitare qui m'a
procuré beaucoup d'émotion parce que
parce que c'était pas une victoire qui
était qui était annoncée avant et je me
suis vraiment battu pour pour gagner et
et quand on travaille beaucoup qu'on se
bat et que là
à l'accomplissement de gagner ça arrive
c'est magnifique en soulevant la coupe
charlotte liothier c'est sûrement
remémorer ces dix dernières années de
golf à haut niveau
la sportive a débuté sur les greens à
l'âge de 12 ans à la réunion avant de
quitter son île en 2014 pour rejoindre
la métropole
aujourd'hui la golf s'épanouit dans cet
écrin saint nom la bretèche depuis plus
de deux ans c'est un club que je ne
connaissais pas du tout honnêtement mais
auquel je tiens beaucoup maintenant
parce que tout le monde est gentil avec
moi depuis toujours
les infrastructures sont bien il ya deux
par course et c'est vraiment bien pour
pouvoir s'entraîner parce qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de golf qui ont deux
parcours
il ya des zones d'entraînement qui sont
quand même très bien et qui sont très
bien entretenus des infrastructures de
haut niveau qui vont lui permettre
d'accomplir l'un de ses premiers
objectifs passé professionnel en fin
d'année une première étape pour viser
ses plus grands rêves numéro 1 mondiale
parce que parce que bah c'est un peu
dans ma tête c'est un peu un objectif un
rêve aussi surtout c'est d'avoir plus
personne devant soi et désire bas je
suis la plus forte du monde pendant un
temps mais je le suis et c'est vraiment
un rêve
autres objectifs envisagés dans les
prochaines années par charlotte liothier
les jeux olympiques et pourquoi pas ceux
de 2024 au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
à 21 ans l'avenir lui appartient